Yeah.
No when you look at the capability today i think it's
also very important question to say well
what is the road map you know how much
better are these systems
and how much more complex
are gonna be the circus that we're able to execute
and for that we have develop a very important metric
are called quantum volume
sometimes you may read or hear in the popular press
the number of cubids and you know
and and as a measure of progress
i'll tell you straight that
just a number of cubits in the machine is not a
good measure of progress
progress needs to be measured by
the level of complexity of the circuit that you can execute
cubits and these good machines are not perfect today
and they have errors i introduce by the coupling of
the system to the external world
the very power of these cubits
of entanglement and those properties
are also make them both powerful
and delicate to the intersection
and connection to the outside world
so you need to lower the error rate
while you increase the cubit count
so that's where it's depicted here
would you really want to do it you want to move in the diagonal
and quantum volume is a measure that incorporates
both of those metrics and some key additional considerations